Una línea recta pasa por los siguientes puntos,
el punto -3, 6 y el punto 6, 0.
Encuentra la ecuación de la linea en,
Inciso a, forma punto-pendiente.
Inciso b, la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen.
Inciso c, la forma estándar.
Y este ejercicio me pareció bastante interesante
porque dice más o menos lo siguiente,
que una línea recta la puedo escribir de las
tres maneras posibles,
así que vamos a recordar cada una de estas maneras.
La forma punto pendiente, si nosotros
tenemos un punto "x1", "y1"
y este punto sabemos que está en nuestra línea recta,
entonces podemos escribir a la línea recta de la siguiente manera, y ojo, aquí hay algo muy importante.
Casi siempre vemos a "y" como una función
de "x", sin embargo aquí lo que me estoy tomando
es un punto particular, un valor que
yo ya me sé, tanto de "x" y de "y", un punto
que sé que está en mi línea recta y si
ya sé, este punto que está en mi línea
recta y ya también conozco la pendiente,
entonces se que la forma punto-pendiente de
una ecuación de una línea recta, es ésta,
"y" - "y1" es igual a "m" que multiplica a "x" menos "x1",
por ejemplo, si en este caso
yo tengo a este punto de aquí y lo quiero
poner en mi ecuación de la forma punto-pendiente,
entonces aquí me quedaría "y" menos 6,
es igual a "m" que multiplica a "x" menos -3, a "x" más 3,
porque menos por menos me daría más.
Bueno, ahorita la vas a ver con mucho más claridad cuando resolvamos este ejercicio.
Así que vamos a pensar en la siguiente.
La forma pendiente ordenada al origen, "y"
es igual a "mx" más "b", esto lo hemos visto
varias veces donde "m" es la pendiente y "b"
mi ordenada al origen
o donde intersectamos al eje de las "y"... el valor,
en donde intersectamos al eje de las "y".
Y la forma estándar es la forma "ax" más "by" igual a "c".
Aquí tengo tanto los valores de "x" como
lo valores de "y" de un lado de la ecuación
y el valor del coeficiente libre del otro
lado de la ecuación.
Así que bueno, lo primero que quiero hacer
para resolver este problema es algo muy importante,
es pensar en la pendiente. Si yo sé la pendiente
de esta recta, pasar de una forma a la otra,
va a ser muy sencilla, pues solamente vamos
a necesitar un poco de álgebra.
Entonces,
¿cuál es la pendiente de esta recta que tengo aquí?
La pendiente que es igual a "m" es el
cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x",
delta de "y" entre delta de "x", o como ya hemos visto
varias veces esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "y2" menos "y1" entre "x2" menos "x1",
la diferencia entre los valores de "y" entre
la diferencia entre los valores de "x",
por lo tanto voy a tomarme a éste como un punto
final y me queda,
"y2" que es 0, menos "y1" que es -6, entonces
0 menos 6 y a esto lo voy a dividir entre
"x2" el cual va a ser 6... "x2" vale 6...
que es el valor de "x" en este punto final,
menos "x1", pero "x1" vale -3, que es el punto inicial.
Fíjate bien, este 0 va a aquí y entonces
abajo tengo que poner su correspondiente coordenada
en "x", este 6 que tengo aquí es el valor
de "y1" y abajo tengo que poner su correspondiente
valor de "x", "x1", para que no te confundas,
este otro 6, es este otro 6, date cuenta que
aquí tengo del punto 6, 0, 6 en "x", 0 en
"y", mientras que hay que restarle el valor
de "x1" que es -3, es decir, 6 menos -3, donde
-3 representa el valor de "x" de este punto,
del punto -3, 6.
Y bueno, ya que tengo aquí todo con orden,
ahora sí, vamos a hacer la correspondiente
operación que tengo aquí,
0 menos 6 es lo mismo que -6...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
0 menos 6 es -6, esta es la diferencia entre
los dos valores que tengo de "y" y después
6 menos -3, es lo mismo que 6 más 3, lo cual
me da 9... 6 menos -3 me va a dar 9,
que es la diferencia entre los valores que tengo
en "x" y me queda -6/9,
pero -6/9 se puede reducir si sacamos tercera arriba y tercera abajo, me queda -2/3.
Y perfecto, ya tengo la pendiente, una vez
que ya tengo la pendiente, entonces me voy
a fijar en el inciso A que dice,
encuentra la ecuación de la recta en la forma
punto-pendiente, así que ya tengo un punto,
ya tengo la pendiente,
ya va a ser fácil encontrar esta forma punto-pendiente.
Déjame ponerlo aquí.
Punto-pendiente.
Y bueno, entonces tengo la ecuación
"y" menos "y1" es igual a "m" por "x" menos "x1",
"y" menos "y1" me voy a tomar este punto,
"y1" vale 6 por lo tanto va a ser "y" menos 6, esto
tiene que ser igual a la pendiente que vale -2/3,
"y" menos 6 es igual a -2/3, que es
la pendiente que multiplica a "x" menos "x1",
pero "x1" es el valor de "x" en este punto
que me estoy tomando, en este punto en particular,
"x" menos -3 y cabe mencionar que sería lo
mismo si tomara yo al otro punto.
Lo único que necesito es un punto que viva
en esta ecuación y me queda que "y" menos
6 es igual a -2/3 por "x", menos por menos
me da más, por "x" más 3.
¡Y aquí está!
ya tengo la primera respuesta, el inciso a,
de esta pregunta.
Ya tengo la forma punto-pendiente de esta recta.
Y bueno, se me hace importante decirte de nuevo que sirve de igual manera si tomamos al otro punto.
A ver, el inciso b dice, vamos a escribir la
ecuación de esta recta en la forma
pendiente-ordenada al origen y bueno para esto me voy a basar en esta que ya tengo aquí.
Lo que voy a hacer es distribuir este -2/3
y despejar a "y" y me queda que "y" menos
6 es igual a -2/3 por "x", es -2/3 de "x"...
"-2/3x" y -2/3 más 3, es más por menos menos,
el 3 y el 3 se cancela y solamente me queda -2.
Y bueno, aquí lo que voy a hacer es sumar
6 de ambos lados de la ecuación y me queda
que... aquí le sumo 6, aquí le sumo 6...
del lado izquierdo se van a cancelar -6 más
6 y solamente me queda "y" y del lado izquierdo
me queda -2/3 de "x" y después -2 más 6
lo cual es 4 positivo, más 4.
"y" igual a -2/3 de "x" más 4 es la solución
del inciso "b" porque fíjate que aquí ya
tengo la pendiente, la pendiente vale -2/3
y además sabemos que intersecta al eje de
las "y" en el valor de 4.
Así que vamos por la última respuesta, la
respuesta del inciso c,
que dice, la ecuación en su forma estándar.
Y la forma estándar es "ax" más "by" igual a "c",
por lo tanto, que te va a parecer si
de esta misma ecuación
en su forma pendiente-ordenada al origen,
yo paso a la "x" del otro lado.
Es decir, lo que voy a hacer aquí es sumar de ambos lados de la ecuación más 2/3 de "x", entonces,
más 2/3 de "x"  y aquí más 2/3 de "x"
y lo que estoy haciendo
es que se cancele la "x" del lado derecho de la ecuación y solamente me queda el término libre
y entonces me queda, más 2/3 de "x" más "y",
déjame ponerlo aquí....
¡ay! creo que no me va a caber...
aquí me va a caber,
más 2/3 de "x" más "y", esto se pasa igual, 2/3 de "x",
aquí le sumo "y", 2/3 de "x" más "y",
estos dos valores se cancelan, -2/3 de "x" más
2/3 de "x" se va y me queda del otro lado 4.
Y aquí ya lo tengo de su forma estándar,
pero casi siempre se pone de la siguiente
manera, para quitar este quebrado que tengo
aquí, esto va a ser exactamente lo mismo
que si yo multiplico todo por 3,
recuerda que si lo que hago de un lado, lo hago del
otro lado entonces la igualdad se conserva.
Entonces voy a multiplicar todo por 3, para
quitar esta fracción y me queda,
2/3 por 3 me da 2, 3 por "y" me da "3y" y 3 por 4
me da 12 y de esta manera ya se ve más clara
la forma estándar de esta ecuación.
Pues aquí ya no tengo fracciones
y se ve quien es a, b y c.